so say for example in this triangle we
know these two sides we have to solve
for that third side so you can see in a
right triangle you can use the
Pythagorean theorem a squared plus B
squared equals C squared so what we have
here to solve for this missing side is
five squared plus twelve squared equals
C squared this is C and this comes out
to 25 plus 144 equals C squared C
squared equals 169 we take the square
root of both sides and you can see that
C is going to come out to 13 okay now we
want to solve for one of these angles
let's just say we want to solve for this
single here first I'll call it angle X
so what trig ratio ties together this
angle this side and say this side well
this one here is the opposite and this
one is the adjacent so we're going to
use the tangent inverse whenever you
want to solve for the missing angle you
use that inverse trig function and we're
going to use tangent since we have
opposite and adjacent because we have
all three sides you could actually use
any three of the trig ratios but let's
just go ahead and use the original
values that they gave us so let's do
tangent inverse of five over twelve so
opposite over adjacent equals x okay so
I'm going to go to the calculator now
and let's calculate what that is so
we've got a tangent inverse five divided
by twelve twenty two point six so this
is twenty two point six degrees this
whole angle here and then what you can
do now is these two angles the two acute
angles in a right triangle they add up
to 90 degrees so by taking ninety minus
twenty two point six we can find the
missing angle so how much is that sixty
seven point four right okay good all
right so now let's try this next example
so here they give us the angle in one of
the sides so let's start maybe by
finding this missing angle so we know
that the three angles add up to 180
that's the triangle sum theorem or we
can just realize that these two angles
are complementary and they add up to 90
so if this is 25 this must be 65 right
okay good
okay now let's let's say we want to
solve for maybe this side right here so
let's use this angle the opposite side
and the adjacent side we'll call this
side X okay so opposite adjacent that's
tangent again so tangents opps over
adjacent and we know the angle now so
when you know the angle and you're using
the angle you just use a regular sine
cosine tangent when you're solving for
the missing angle that's when you use
the inverse trig functions okay so
that's important to remember so tangent
of 25° so it's sine cosine or tangent of
the angle equals the ratio of the two
sides in this case opposite over
adjacent
you can cross multiply or you can switch
these on the diagonal okay so I'm just
going to interchange these and I've got
x equals 4 divided by the tangent of 25°
so let's go to the calculator on that
one we've got 4 divided by the tangent
of 25/8 point 6 approximately so this is
eight point six okay now we're just
missing the third side which you can see
it's the hypotenuse you've got a couple
options you can either do the
Pythagorean theorem a squared plus B
squared equals C squared the only
downside to that is because we rounded
this answer when we get to the this side
we round again we may be a little bit
off so what I tend to do on these
problems and what you might want to do
too is see if you can go back to the
original numbers the other benefit of
this is if you made a mistake on one of
these you won't carry that mistake
forward in your problem and get the rest
of the questions wrong so let's go back
to this one
we've got 25 we've got 4 and we want to
find this side let's call it Y so that's
going to be opposite over hypotenuse
which you can see that's ops over
hypotenuse that's the sine ratio and so
let's go ahead and do that so sine of 25
degrees so sine of the angle equals the
ratio of the opposite side over the
hypotenuse anything divided by 1 is
itself you can cross multiply so that's
going to give you Y times the sine of 25
equals 4 times 1 which is 4 divide both
sides by sine of 25 okay those are gonna
cancel out and y equals 4 divided by the
sine of 25 so we'll just go to the
calculator real quick and see what that
comes out to 9.5 approximately can't
just run it to the nearest tenth 9.5 so
you solve the triangle you found all the
angles all the sides that's what they
mean when they say solving the right
triangle just remember if you're solving
for the angle use the inverse trig
functions if you know the angle take the
sine cosine tangent of that angle and it
equals the ratio of the two sides if
you're enjoying these videos and you're
getting something out of them as I hope
you are go ahead and subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and I'll see you in the next video